completa la tabla para mostrar medidas
equivalentes en minutos y segundos y
bueno aquí tengo los minutos y los
segundos pero lo primero que quiero que
recuerdes es que nosotros sabemos que en
un minuto hay 60 segundos y por lo tanto
vamos a escribirlo aquí en un minuto hay
60 segundos ahora quiero saber cuántos
segundos hay en tres minutos y para
saber cuántos segundos hay en tres
minutos
bueno pues habrá que multiplicar tres
por 60 segundos o dicho de otra manera 3
que multiplica a 60 segundos por minuto
y por lo tanto aquí me van a quedar 180
segundos ahora aquí tengo 7 minutos y 7
minutos quiero ver cuántos segundos
tiene bueno voy a multiplicar 7 por 60
segundos por cada minuto y eso me va a
quedar 7 por 60 lo cuales 420 420 ahora
por último quiero saber cuántos segundos
hay en 12 minutos
voy a multiplicar 12 minutos por 60
segundos por cada minuto y eso me va a
quedar 600 más 120 720 segundos
ok es hora de comprobar la respuesta y
de lujo